STATES SAID YES.
THERE IS REASON TO BELIEVE AN
ATTACK COULD COME IN THE COMING
WEEK, IN THE COMING DAYS.
MATTHEW CHANCE IS IN KYIV FOR US
RIGHT NOW.
POWERFUL WORDS FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
I'M SURE IT WILL STARTLE ALL THE
FOLK WHO ARE WHERE YOU ARE.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
I'VE NOT HEARD, NONE OF US HAVE
HEARD THE U.S. PRESIDENT TALK
ABOUT IT IN SUCH STARK TERMS AS
THAT.
HE WAS EVEN PRESSED BY ONE OF
THE REPORTERS.
HOW DO YOU KNOW HE'S MADE THAT
DECISION?
HE SAID BECAUSE WE HAVE
CONSIDERABLE INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITY, REVEALING THERE THAT
THEY, OR SAYING AT LEAST, THAT
THEY HAVE AN INSIGHT INTO WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN INTENDS TO DO.
AND LOOK, IT IS SUCH A MASSIVE
DEPARTURE FROM THE SITUATION
WE'RE IN JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO.
JUST SIX MONTHS AGO.
JUST LAST WEEK.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING THAT WHOLE
PERIOD ABOUT THE BUILD-UP OF
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TROOPS BY
RUSSIA, NEAR BORDERS OF UKRAINE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW
RUSSIA POSES A REAL THREAT OR
GIVES THE IMPRESSION OF POSING A
THREAT.
RIGHT UNTIL THE 11th HOUR, THE
59th MINUTE OF THE 11th HOUR, AS
WE KEEP ON SAYING.
VLADIMIR PUTIN COULD DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO PULL THE
TRIGGER ON AN INVASION.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS NOW SAYING IS THAT HE
BELIEVES THAT DECISION AT THE
KREMLIN TO INVADE UKRAINE HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN TAKEN.
WE'VE ALREADY REACHED OUT TO MY
CONTACTS AT THE KREMLIN.
THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN BACK.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE IS
GOING TO HEAD TO THE SECURITY
CONFERENCE, EVEN THOUGH U.S.
OFFICIALS ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
THE RUSSIANS WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
MAYBE AFTER HEARING THOSE
REMARKS BY PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE
WILL THINK AGAIN ABOUT HIS
TRAVEL PLANS.
I SPOKE TO UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS A
FEW MINUTES AGO ABOUT THOSE
TRAVEL PLANS AND THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE WHITE HOUSE, THAT
IF PRESIDENT ZELENSKY LEAVES THE
COUNTRY, IT COULD BE A CONFLICT
STARTING, FLIGHTS, BACK AGAIN,
IT COULD BE PERCEIVED AS A SENSE
IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COUNTRY HAS LEFT THE COUNTRY
AHEAD OF AN INVASION.
AND WHAT THE UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS
I SPOKE TO THAT, LOOK, DIPLOMACY
IS HE MOMENT IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THE FRONT LINE IN
EASTERN UKRAINE.
AND IT IS INCONCEIVABLE, I'M
SLIGHTLY PARAPHRASING HERE, THAT
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTRY
WOULDN'T ENGAGE IN THAT KIND OF
DIPLOMACY AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY SEE.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THERE IS A
MEETING SCHEDULED WITH U.S.
PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY.
>> STAND BY.
I WANT TO BRING JIM SCIUTTO INTO
THIS.
YOU'VE BEEN REPORTING ON THIS
ALL DAY THAT THERE HAS BEEN IN
RECENT DAYS, A PALPABLE CHANGE
AMONG U.S. AND NATO OFFICIALS.
WE HEARD THAT DIRECTLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT MOMENTS AGO.
>> Reporter: THE PALPABLE CHANGE
BEING THEY HAVE A BLEAK
ASSESSMENT OF RUSSIAN INTENTIONS
HERE.
YOU HEARD THAT VERY DIRECTLY,
VERY PUBLICLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK WE NEED TO REITERATE
THAT FROM THE U.S. PRESIDENT
SAYING A DECISION HAS BEEN MADE.
TO THIS POINT THE DECISION HAS
BEEN, THEY HAVE THE
CAPABILITIES, THEY HAVE ALL THE
FORCES THEY NEED TO LAUNCH A
COMPREHENSIVE INVASION OF
UKRAINE, BUT THAT PUTIN HAD NOT
MADE THAT DECISION.
THE U.S. PRESIDENT SAYS, IN
FACT, THE LATEST ASSESSMENT IS
THAT HE HAS MADE THAT DECISION.
THE OTHER NOTABLE COMMENT WAS
THE PRESIDENT SAYING, ATTACKING
HERE IN THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL
KYIV IS PART OF THE PLAN.
I'VE BEEN REPORTING FOR SOME
TIME, AT THE HIGHER END OF
RUSSIAN OPTIONS HERE, PUTIN'S
OPTIONS HERE, WAS A BROAD SCALE
INVASION FROM THE SOUTH, THE
EAST, INCLUDING DOWN HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OF UKRAINE.
BUT THAT IS CONSIDERED NOT AN
OUTLIER BUT THE MOST DRAMATIC
DECISION THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
COULD MAKE HERE.
THE U.S. PRESIDENT JUST SAID, HE
BELIEVES UKRAINE, SORRY, KYIV,
IS A TARGET OF THAT INVASION
PLAN.
THAT'S A REMARKABLE THING TO
SAY.
THAT THIS IS A CAPITAL, A FREE
CAPITAL OF A SOVEREIGN EUROPEAN
STATE IN THE YEAR 2022.
AND THE U.S. BELIEVES RUSSIA NOT
ONLY HAS THE FORCES TO TAKE OVER
THIS CAPITAL, BUT NOW, THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT HAS MADE THE
DECISION TO DO SO AS WELL.
THAT'S QUITE A MOMENT IN THESE
WEEKS, FRANKLY, A BUILD-UP TO
THE THREAT OF UKRAINE.
>> LET'S NOT FORGET WHERE YOU
ARE, THE CITY OF KYIV, A CITY OF
ALMOST 3 MILLION PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW.
AND WE JUST HEARD PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAY THAT CITY IS ABOUT TO
BE ATTACKED BY THE RUSSIANS.
ABBY PHILLIP, GIVE US A SENSE OF
HOW CRITICAL A MOMENT THIS IS
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
INDEED, FOR THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: I THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN WAS BASICALLY PREPARING
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AS HE AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION HAVE FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS NOW FOR A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT EVENT.
A SIGNIFICANT EVENT FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND FOR EUROPE.
IF RUSSIA WERE TO INVADE UKRAINE
IN THE WAY DESCRIBE, THAT COULD
MEAN SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FIGHTING IN EUROPE
SINCE THE END OF WORLD WAR II.
THAT'S NOTHING TO TAKE LIGHTLY.
YOU SEE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF IT
IN THE WAY THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
AIDES HAVE BEEN TRYING TO SAY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT, WHILE
WE ARE NOT GOING TO PUT OUR
SOLDIERS ON THE LINE, THIS
MATTERS TO US.
AND THE COROLLARY TO THAT IS,
THIS COULD HAVE EFFECTS ON US AS
A COUNTRY IN TERMS OF HOW GAS
PRICES ARE AFFECTED, AND OUR
BROADER SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN A VERY
PIVOTAL MOMENT.
HE JUST CAME OFF THE EXPERIENCE.
AFGHANISTAN THAT WAS
EMBARRASSING FOR HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS A MOMENT TO SHOW
LEADERSHIP ON THE GLOBAL STAGE
AND TO RESTORE A SENSE OF
COMPENSATIONY FROM THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC THAT HE AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE CAPABLE OF
MANAGING.
A REALLY THORNY AND TRICKY
SITUATION IN UKRAINE.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY DANGEROUS
MOMENT INDEED.
NOT JUST FOR EUROPE.
FOR THE WORLD.
EVERYBODY STAND BY.
I WANT TO BRING IN RETIRED U.S.
GENERAL PHILLIP REID, THE FORMER
COMMANDER IN EUROPE.
GIVE US YOUR REACTION FROM THE
OMINOUS WORDS WE JUST HEARD FROM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> THANKS, WOLF.
FOR SURE WE HAVE SEEN FOR A
NUMBER OF DAYS THAT MR. PUTIN
HAD A FORCE THAT WAS READY AND
CAPABLE.
NOT BEING EXPOSED TO EVERYTHING
THE PRESIDENT THAT, IT IS CLEAR
HE BELIEVES THIS WILL HAPPEN.
I THINK THIS IS A TOUGH JUDGMENT
TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
APPARENTLY MR. PUTIN HAS LOOKED
AT WHAT HE SEES THE WEST IS
PREPARED TO DO AND HE HAS DECIDE
THAT HAD IT IS WORTH IT FOR HIM
TO MAKE THIS ADVENTURE.
>> BUT YOU HEARD, HE AND THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE WILL PAY A VERY,
VERY STEAM PRICE.
NOT ONLY SANCTIONS FROM THE
U.S., THE NATO ALLIES, THE
EUROPEAN UNION, SO MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT AN ENORMOUS POLITICAL PRICE.
RUSSIA WILL BE ISOLATED, AND
ALSO, IN TERMS OF CASUALTIES, IF
THERE IS A FULL-SCALE WAR, A LOT
OF RUSSIAN TROOPS WILL BE
KILLED.
IS PUTIN READY FOR THAT?
>> Reporter: WELL, IF HE
INVADES, THEN HE'S MADE THE
DECISION THAT HE'S READY FOR IT.
THAT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
YOU ARE RIGHT THOUGH.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE NOT IN
HIS FAVOR.
REMEMBER, IT WAS THE MOMS IN
MOSCOW THAT GAVE HIM SO MUCH
TROUBLE AFTER THE LAST INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
AND HIS OWN PROBLEMS AT HOME
WITH YOUNG SOLDIERS COMING HOME
IN BODY BAGS.
SO HE HAS TO HAVE THIS IN HIS
CALCULUS.
I THINK THOUGH THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO SANCTIONS, WHAT HE'S
SEEN IN THE PAST THAT HE CAN
WEATHER THEM PEOPLE HAVE OFTEN
ASKED, HAS IT CHANGED PUTIN.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT IT HAS NOT
CHANGED HIS BEHAVIOR.
BECAUSE AFTER '08, WE SANCTIONED
HIM.
AFTER SANCTIONED HIM.
AND NOW HE'S BACK.
THE U.S. WHO IS THE DELIVER SO
HE DOESN'T COME BACK IN TWO OR
THREE YEARS.
>> NIC ROBERTSON IS ON THE SCENE
FOR US.
DO THEY APPRECIATE THE ENORMITY
OF WHAT IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SAYING IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS, THIS WEEK, RUSSIA IS ABOUT
TO INVADE UKRAINE?
AND THERE WILL BE ENORMOUS
FALLOUT.
DO FOLKS IN MOSCOW WHERE YOU ARE
APPRECIATE THAT?
>> Reporter: I DON'T THINK THEY
FULLY APPRECIATE WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN.
I THINK THEY THINK THERE'S A
RESILIENCE IN RUSSIA AT THE
MOMENT AND I THINK PART OF
PUTIN'S CALCULATION MAY ALSO BE,
THAT EVEN WHEN HE HAD THE
PROBLEM WITH THE MOSCOW MOMS AND
THE BODY BAGS COMING BACK FROM
THE INVASION AND THE ANNEXATION
OF CRIMEA, HIS OWN POPULARITY
RATING WENT THROUGH THE ROOF.
IT WAS IN THE 90s.
IT IS IN THE 60s NOW.
GETTING BACK TO WHAT WAS SAID
ABOUT THIS MORE AND MORE
DISINFORMATION, THE FABRICATION
AND THE CAUSE TO GO TOER WITH A,
THAT IS WHAT RUSSIAN VIEWERS
HAVE BEEN SEEING ON THEIR TVs
THIS AFTERNOON.
AS THE TWO REBEL LEADERS FROM
DONETSK IN EASTERN UKRAINE
CALLED ON THE CIVILIANS TO GET
ON BUSS AND DRIVE TO TAKE
SHELTER INSIDE RUSSIA.
THE IMAGES BEING PLAYED ON STATE
TELEVISION HEAR, AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU QUITE INCREDIBLE.
BECAUSE ON THE MAIN SCREEN THAT
WAS PLAYING, IT WAS HOW TO -- IT
WAS REDECORATING YOUR HOUSE.
YET IN A LITTLE BOX ON THE
SCREEN WERE PEOPLE, YOUNG
CHILDREN, GETTING READY TO BE
LOADED ON TO BUSES OR PEOPLE
PACKING BAGS TO EVACUATE ON A
PERMANENT LOOP.
SO IT WAS REALLY GINNING UP THAT
IDEA THAT PEOPLE ARE UNDER
THREAT.
THE VULNERABLE ARE UNDER THREAT.
THAT RUSSIA NEEDS TO HELP THEM.
TO GET TO PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POINT THAT HE APPEARS TO HAVE
MADE THE CALCULATION THAT PUTIN
HAS MADE THE DECISION TO INVADE.
BIDEN WAS ASKED, IS THERE STILL
SPACE FOR DIPLOMACY, AND HE
SAID, I'M NOT SURE THAT HE WANTS
DIPLOMACY.
THE UNDERLYING THING THAT BESIDE
THE MILITARY BUILD-UP HAS BEEN
THIS POTENTIALLY FABRICATED
NARRATIVE OF DIPLOMACY.
THAT'S WHAT BIDEN IS TALKING
ABOUT WITH FABRICATIONS.
>> JIM SCIUTTO -- GO AHEAD.
>> SINCE WORLD WAR II.
IF THESE PREDICTIONS BEAR OUT.
IT IS OTHER SOBERING MOM